all right Steve
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally Antelope Valley
California
tell me about your family
um I was raised mostly by my
grandparents my mom and dad are both
junkies um my mom's a heroin addict
prostitute
she's in Bakersfield now she's the only
one I do talk to still
my dad was a crack addict
um didn't really have any connection
with him you know
like I said it was raised my grandma so
you're raised by your grandparents yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general good it wasn't bad uh I did see
things I shouldn't have seen of course
you know the drugs were a big part of
that so
I became addicted to drugs as I got
older as well so when did you start
playing around with harder drugs
uh right around 14 or 15 years old
so around the time I became a dad so
yeah I had my first kid at 14. 14. I
think I was using heroin at 14. yeah
yeah and the the mother of your child is
she's sober now but she was using as
well how old was she she was uh
she's two years or 16 years old at the
time yeah
she was using her own as well she's the
one that got me into it so
any traumatic events or anything like
that in your childhood uh no nothing
um besides never seen our parents I mean
that's traumatic enough that's as
traumatic as it really got you know
nothing too crazy
um
as far as I I'm concerned my brothers
and sisters went through a little bit
different stuff
you know they were raised with my mom
and dad they're older than I am so
I'm sure they went through a lot
different you think you were better off
too yeah oh yeah
my mom is uh
very uh straightforward with what she
does
you know she has no no concern of
anybody else just does what she wants
she's a great she's actually a really
nice woman she's cool but she's
lets everything hang out you know
it's too much for me
at school excuse me how far did you go
in school uh I went to ninth grade I
didn't go much further I was bored in
school at a very young age like
just didn't concern me you know I had my
first kid really young too so
yeah what'd you do after that
um I got really into working I started
working at a young age uh worked for
this AV patio and Fireside doing
firework fireplaces cleaning chimneys
and
driving trucks that's how I first
started driving trucks and then after
that from 16 to
22. I drove like big rigs Class A
Vehicles things like that
all while you're using oh well using
this
I was using and working
all the way up until about a couple
years ago
so what are you doing now uh now I am
homeless on the Streets of L.A
and using fentanyl I'm using Fentanyl
and Crystal
um a caviar crack
so what do you mix the two
um I mix all three all three yeah the
the crack in the nuts I do it oh yeah
we'll give you a little yeah
because he gives me a I guess the
Comfort I'm looking for you could say
well the the fentanyl will put you to
sleep yeah it helps me relax a little
bit and the other ones keep you up yeah
it's that big it's that big old
jumbled mix it it's what I'm looking for
I guess
how do you support yourself now
um I'm a booster
I boost there's still things I you're a
thief I'm a thief very much so
um
not proud of it but
that's what I do so I gotta make money I
gotta eat seven o'clock before excuse me
have you been caught before oh yeah yeah
uh probably four or five times this week
four or five times this week yeah and
what do they do uh I got a big big
arrest record
um usually just get let out you know 24
hours they're pretty quick with it it's
one of those things so
they don't they don't really hold on to
it too much too much if it's a
misdemeanor or anything
over 900 bucks is a felony so you just
don't go that high
what would you
say is the biggest factor and why you're
in this situation today it's similar to
what your parents were going through
um so
basically
my daughter was murdered when we were
when I was 22 years old
um
somebody
came into our home
in the middle of the night
I was asleep the night before me and my
wife who got really drunk Xanax whatever
else you know
so it was hard for me I didn't really
know I didn't hear anything I didn't
know what was going on they didn't shake
me awake and when I did did awake
uh there was a man in our house who had
I didn't know at the time I'd rape my
daughter and choked her to death you
know so
I killed him I went after him I picked a
hammer out of my head out of my tool bag
and
just went after him
yeah yeah
I'm 37 now so this happened this
happened a long time ago yeah
your daughter was how old
four months old
which is
just a baby yeah just a baby it has to
go a little much
so that's a setback for yeah I uh anyone
I went to jail for six years
for um
killing the guy of course you know
I I overkilled I don't know what I did I
pretty much blacked out
I guess I dragged him out front did some
other things you know
I I really don't
remember it so I just know I did the
time for it and uh while I was in I
ended up getting a couple more years as
an add-on
for drugs you know
and when I got out I actually went right
back to normal life I
got a career driving trucks again
classic vehicles I still have my license
you know why not doing it I don't know
um
and I did that up until about two years
ago I drove for Coors the Beer Company
and two years ago what happened covid or
something no I uh me and my wife
separated
and I think that was
a huge factor into why I am right where
I'm at right now
you know I just I guess I didn't see it
coming and it
broke me up pretty good
I assume that losing your child must be
very hard for you and your wife still is
I don't know for all those years
still is it's like so I can't even talk
about everybody but I don't know I've
never really talked about it to anybody
okay it's just one of those things
it's hard to talk about you don't really
want to bring that up in a situation or
during conversation you know
most people don't want to hear about
that you know
what a horrible thing for a parent to go
through
this whole is definitely horrible it
[ __ ] my wife up pretty good
she ended up getting on night pills and
you know psych meds all those things
while I was locked up
that definitely changed her as a you
know as a human and who she became
she was doing well in life you know she
was a vet tech just going somewhere you
know now
she's on SSI and you know basically
let it all slip out you know it's always
all gone after that
so and you're you're on the streets
doing fentanyl yeah
yeah how does this affect you
emotionally it's going to get you down
um
my emotions are pretty much
topped off with the drugs you know
they don't come out unless they don't
have them
I mean truthfully that hurt like talking
about that now just brought up a little
bit
but I am sober right now too so
it's hard it's hard it's a hard subject
very difficult
um
you're staying you're staying on the
streets in your tent uh no I'm just a
floater I just sort of just go where I
go and
get by how I get by you know I stay
wherever
um if I'm not in La I'll be in like
Monrovia or
I'll go to Long Beach anywhere away from
here usually I don't like this place
very much yeah this is not a place for
anyone L.A is not a very livable place
well done downtown for sure downtown for
sure it's very dangerous
um
being here for the last two years I've
seen some things down here you just
couldn't believe you know like like what
just just the people I mean the people
out here how how
I guess our government doesn't do
anything for anybody out here it's
it's pretty sad you know
or maybe they're just not doing it for
themselves I don't know
but it's pretty hardcore out here the
drug use you could do it you could use
your drugs right in front of the cops no
one will stop you
do you feel helpless against your
fentanyl addiction yes very much so
right now I do
um I'm looking into actually getting
into a rehab type situation I want to be
done with it
been too long too much you know I want
to get get some stuff done for my family
I
my wife wants me to come home which is
amazing I didn't expect her to say that
but yeah
that's nice
my kids I don't talk to him very much
like I should
and it's all because of the drug use
yeah I'm ashamed of it I'm ashamed to be
who I am right now you know do you have
other children I do I have four kids
four two yeah I have four children uh 19
16 13 and 9.
two girls two boys
what's your biggest fear
dying alone
pretty much
yeah
dying in a tent or somewhere
you know from the Fentanyl
dude yeah good good handful of times
yeah
that's scary
and I actually just did recently
um like two weeks ago IOD
INE
and that's what I just thought about the
rehab thing you know I need to get into
it I need to do something different yeah
or I will die out here
so happens every day I see it every day
saw one yesterday you know I tried to
help the kid and I sometimes just can't
doesn't happen all the time you know
even with the ambulances you know it
sucks
they come and they still can't get them
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I don't even know
I locked the doors in the house
and I'll let somebody get in there
protected my family a little bit better
because I think this is all from that
it's all started there you know but I
went to jail I never
I was never like a
like a bad kid or anything you know I
never
never committed a crime in my life you
know so
going straight from
fatherhood to jail was like tough you
know
learning that
learning that curveball was it was
something I never wanted to learn
learned how to be real tough you know
just deal with [ __ ]
so I just wish I could go back and
let my kids know
you know I am sorry
that I didn't just stick with it
stay there you know stay the course
instead I get swallowed up with the
drugs
I just
hey my emotions away with a man there's
this kind of simple it's nice that your
wife hasn't given up on you
I'm very surprised I don't know how she
does it don't she's sober now four years
and you're just like killing it I don't
know how she does it
I don't
she found a way to love herself you know
like I hope you do that
it's pretty cool yeah that's really the
key isn't it yeah I think so like that's
why I want to get into a good rehab or
something you know
somebody I just need to talk to people I
think
I don't think I've ever really talked
about this before so even right now it's
pretty difficult like therapy is great
that's
something I'm not used to
very nervous what was your favorite
memory in your life favorite memory of
my life uh
I used to be used to go rock climbing
with my dad
and it was just all my brothers and
sisters I have a lot of them
and that was like the best best times of
my life
but that was my favorite memory and then
my children were born
it was gross but it was cool I think it
was awesome
that was just
it's amazing you know
that came out of me into her and made
that it was like my son's six foot three
yeah I think I'll do
it's
crazy
I wish I was there more for him you know
yeah
I'd love to be
Steve what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
be humble
to uh keep your friends close and your
enemies closer and
always always always [ __ ] be there
for your family like
she's like coming out here and having
nothing to nobody
it sucks
you know
it sucks
if you could change it go back and do
whatever you got to do to make things
right with your family man like that's
like the number one thing you know
I just wish I could
I think I can just gotta do it yeah
all right Steve I wish you the best of
luck with it thank you thank you so much